foreign
HD here and welcome to a Hands-On and
first look of a really interesting new
folding phone the Moto Razer plus so you
know how a lot of these foldable phones
have kind of felt like a small bump up
from the previous one they're all kind
of similar for both the folding and
flipping phones
well this one feels like a big jump
forward for the first time in a while it
feels like we're sort of Leaping into
the second generation of these flipping
phone things and it's pretty obvious why
so this Razer plus which is the fourth
generation of the folding phone from
Motorola is going to have a gigantic
screen on the outside cover now gigantic
is of course a relative term but in a
small phone that folds in half and fits
in your pocket having a 3.6 inch 144
Hertz poled display that goes basically
corner to corner all the way around the
front and even as pixels around the
cameras and the Flash cutouts is pretty
dramatically different from what we had
before now the rest of the phone is
pretty solid too right I can't quite
call it a flagship since it doesn't
really have the highest end available
specs but it's pretty close feels like
upper you know premium mid-range and the
retail price is going to be 9.99 when it
launches in a few weeks this summer
they've kind of slowly dropped the Retro
throwback aesthetic from the first
generation of this thing and they've
tightened up the edges and modernized
the whole thing the huge chin is gone
and inside it's a Snapdragon 8 plus gen
one eight gigs of RAM 256 gigs of
storage and a decent sized 3 800
milliamp hour battery with 30 watt
charging and 5 watt wireless charging so
yeah not any sort of crazy world beater
Flagship specs but still pretty solid I
I will note that the 3 800 milliamp hour
battery is a thousand milliamp hours
greater than the previous gen razor this
thing only had a 2800 milliamp hour
battery so that puts it right in line
with the current z-flip the four which
has a 3700 milliamp hour and then on the
inside the main folding display is a 6.9
inch 22 by 9 1080p poled display and
it's 165 Hertz ltpo display it's not the
brightest thing I've ever seen but hey
for a folding phone I think it looks
really good it's got the hole punch
selfie camera at the top the bezels are
even thinner and the crease it's not
revolutionary it's about as subtle as
I've seen in some other folding phones
with its redesigned aluminum hinge
mechanism it definitely disappears when
you're looking at the content and just
using the phone but none of that is why
this feels like a new generation it
feels like a new generation of course
because of the giant outside display so
let's talk about it this new outside
display is really interesting for two
reasons one because it's basically what
we're also expecting based on the rumors
and leaks from what we've seen of
Samsung's next flip the flip 5. it's
probably also coming out later this
summer
but also too because this it does throw
a wrench in like how you use a phone
like this so like I said this is the 3.6
inch 144hz display that basically covers
the entire outside of this phone right
up to get near the hinge where I assume
the digitizer is the two primary cameras
a 12 megapixel primary and the 13
megapixel Ultra wide slash macro and the
Flash are cutouts with even more pixels
around them and in between them and so
you can basically do anything you want
on this outside screen in its resting
state it's just a clock of course but
you can change between a bunch of
different clock Styles they all have
black backgrounds so they look pretty
seamless on the OLED you also get some
basic notifications at the bottom left
corner and the ability to manage those
notifications when you swipe down from
the top you have a whole bunch of quick
controls things like brightness and
Wi-Fi and a flashlight and whatever
media is currently playing but then when
you wake it up and unlock with a swipe
up from the bottom or a fingerprint
unlock you basically get this entire
home screen with a wallpaper and a bunch
of pages of these things widgets
shortcuts Etc now these are limited
preset Pages they're actually called
panels and you can turn them on or off
or rearrange them in the settings but
they do have a variety of things there's
a home panel with the clock and the
weather and shortcuts to other panels
but then of course a calendar panel and
a weather panel and a contacts panel and
you can put them in whatever order you
want there's also a Spotify one
apparently they've worked with Spotify
to create this perfectly optimized one
and I do think it looks pretty good but
also you can just use whatever app you
want on the outside screen there is a
settings page that lets you enable
almost any app on your phone to work on
the outside screen and control the
continuity settings so when you open and
close the phone the app stays open which
is super useful honestly it sounds
pretty great since you can take photos
and navigate with Google Maps and pay
with gpay and do all kinds of convenient
stuff without even opening the phone
that's the whole point of the outside
screen but it also goes so much further
than that you can make and receive phone
calls with the phone still closed you
can use a whole scientific calculator on
the outside screen there's a whole
keyboard for typing out messages if you
want to send emails or text messages
from the outside there's even games of
course these are bordering on gimmicky
but there's literally games that
Motorola built to play on this outside
screen like this one where you feed the
marble to the end of the maze which is
of course the camera cutout
like you can watch YouTube videos on
this thing if you want to it's going to
be a weird Square aspect ratio with all
of this but yeah there's basically no
limit to what you can do on this outside
display it's a super screen it can do
whatever you want the screen to do
um but
hear me out I don't actually know if
that's what people want because the more
I think about it just just zoom out a
little bit with me those uh hot dog
style folding phones like the big
folding phones those are all
productivity monsters you got the screen
on the inside and the outside those are
for people who want to do as much as
possible and fit as big of a screen as
they possibly can in their pockets great
but then these little flipping phones
they've always been smaller and they've
always been a little bit more regular
and I think it's also kind of nice to
have a barrier between uh using your
phone and not using your phone so if
there's just something small and there's
a notification you can clear it but I
won't get sucked into like scrolling
through Tick Tock endlessly or Instagram
reels because I will have to open the
phone for that
but now on this one you can get sucked
into tick tocks on the outside screen so
is this a good thing I mean for me yeah
I mean I I love having tons of
functionality on the outside the more
the better and they've even built some
extra stuff the whole outside screen can
be a viewfinder for the camera and
there's also this half folded mode that
you can use to hold the phone where it
feels like an old camcorder from back in
the day but the subject can still see
themselves there's a lot of cool stuff
but yeah I wonder if the customer of a
flipping phone like this actually has
that like super high on their priority
list you know something to think about
actually Motorola literally alongside
this phone also announced the new Razer
so this is the Razer plus we've been
talking about with the huge screen for a
thousand bucks but the Razer will come
out later this summer and it's also a
folding phone but with just the tiny one
and a half inch postage stamp size
display on the outside just like from
the earliest flipping phones which I
don't know just seems to make a lot of
sense and the rest of the phone will
have just slightly lower end specs like
it's a Snapdragon 7 gen one it's a 144hz
internal display instead of 165. it's
128 gigs of storage instead of 256. it's
a vegan leather back instead of Gorilla
Glass victis and it's still ip52 water
resistant but they didn't tell us the
price of this phone so I'm guessing just
based on context
and knowing that it's probably going to
be meaningfully cheaper for this new
phone to exist this might be like a 599
to 7.99 brand new folding phone and
that's also really interesting plus also
because it doesn't have the huge outside
screen it has room for a larger battery
4 200 milliamp hours and a larger
primary camera 64 megapixel camera so a
little lighter on the wallet a little
bit more space for other things kind of
interesting also speaking of wallets
this one's a little bit lighter in your
pocket too you can get it at
shop.whd.com but that's it let me know
what you think of the giant outside
screen on The Flipping phone is it truly
second gen is this where we're going
with them all or is this kind of
Overkill I'll hang out in the comments
for this one I'm really curious what you
guys think either way thanks for
watching catch you later peace
foreign